[Música]
no rio de janeiro onde eu nasci vivi
trabalho a riqueza ea pobreza extrema
convivem lado a lado infelizmente isso
não é uma realidade só no brasil mas no
mundo todo
segundo as nações unidas 1 bilhão de
pessoas ainda sofrem com a fome no mundo
no brasil são 7,4 milhões de pessoas 1
bilhão também não têm moradia adequada
2,4 bilhões não têm acesso a saneamento
básico
um quarto da população brasileira não
tem esse acesso
segundo a organização mundial de saúde
um terço das mortes ainda hoje ocorrem
por doenças relacionadas à pobreza fome
diarréia tuberculose pneumonia malária
doenças essas que poderiam ser
facilmente tratadas ou prevenidos a
baixo custo essa realidade é
inadmissível e logo apareceu quando me
formei nutrição e fui fazer uma
especialização no materno infantil
era o início da década de 90 o auge da
epidemia de aids e ouvia diversas mães
que não podiam amamentar seus filhos mas
também não tinham dinheiro pra comprar
os leites e fórmulas especiais elas
muitas vezes não tinham dinheiro nem
para o transporte por aí e voltar para
as consultas e os anos os remédios que
elas tomavam eram muito fortes e isso
fazia com que os efeitos colaterais
fossem grandes e os cuidados com os
filhos fossem ainda mais difíceis
uma das minhas maiores frustrações era
ver em internações não por causa da
doença
mas pelas condições de miséria que essas
pessoas viviam elas adoeciam eram
internadas tratadas voltavam para casa
para as condições de miséria e muitas
vezes se internavam
condições ainda piores eu ficava
impotente achava que não tinha solução
para isso e acabei me afastando da saúde
pública mas continuou aquela angústia e
aquela dor no meu coração e eu pensando
tem que ter uma solução pra isso aí eu
comecei a ouvir falar de um projecto
saúde criança e resolvi 1999 me
candidatar voluntária
chegando lá eu conhecer a doutora vera
cordeiro médica que trabalhou por mais
de 20 anos no hospital federal da lagoa
no rio
lá ela tratou de centenas de pacientes
viu muitas internações e ela viu o
desespero dos pais na hora da alta que
eles sabiam que iam para casa e não iam
ter condições de continuar o tratamento
dos seus filhos
ela percebeu então que não adiantava só
o ato médico só o seu trabalho como
médica muito teria que ser feito para
resolver a situação dessas pessoas o que
precisava ser tratado era miséria a
causa de um círculo vicioso a criança do
e cia
por causa das condições em que vivia era
internada tratada e voltava para as
mesmas condições que tinham feito a
doença da primeira vez era então
reinternado e muitas vezes morria ela
percebeu que só tratará do estado físico
não era o suficiente e resolveu abrir
uma instituição para tratar das demandas
necessidades sociais dessas famílias
foi nesse momento que eu me juntei a ela
ea diversos voluntários para tentar
atender essas demandas sociais não só do
ano medicamentos alimentos dinheiro para
o transporte mas também pensando em como
essas famílias
após os dois anos em média que ficam no
projeto podiam se auto-sustentar foi um
vindo de baixo pra cima essas famílias
que a gente atendia que a metodologia do
saúde criança foi sendo formada
caso a mudar em breve
que tinha seis filhos e um dia chegou
desesperada chorando que os filhos sejam
retirados dela
nesse dia eu fui um assistente social e
um motorista de saúde criança até onde
essa família morava e o que ouvi me
choca ainda hoje
eles moravam debaixo das condições de
uma casa num buraco cavado na terra não
tinha luz não tinha água não tinha
saneamento era uma miséria insalubridade
totais ou ainda um caso da ana maria
chegou no saúde criança com quatro
filhos sendo que o mais novo tinha
síndrome dão e dos problemas cardíacos e
ele só viviam da renda do marido dela
que era atendente numa padaria a irmã
dela que era viciada em drogas
faleceu de uma overdose e ana maria
ainda pegou os três filhos da irmã para
criar sendo que essas crianças antes
viviam na rua não tinham nenhum
documento nunca tinham frequentado uma
creche ou escola ou ainda o caso da
gláucia e tinha dois filhos com uma
doença genética séria vivia mais no
hospital do que em casa e quando um
filho internado ela tinha que levar o
outro porque não tinha com quem deixar
toda renda dessa família eo benefício de
prestação continuada do governo um
salário mínimo
vendo esses casos a gente viu que a
pobreza multidimensional envolve muitas
coisas e só uma intervenção em muitas
áreas também poderia transformar a vida
dessas famílias
nós começamos então a construir a
metodologia do saúde criança o plano de
ação familiar com ações em cinco áreas
saúde educação moradia cidadania e
geração de renda
na saúde não só do andu medicamentos
exames e equipamentos médicos mas também
explicando para a família o diagnóstico
prognóstico tratamento e acompanhando
para ver se as vacinas estão em dia
estão indo nas consultas na parte de
geração de renda
percebendo quais habilidades e
possibilidades dessas famílias para
gerar renda
normalmente são famílias com baixíssima
escolaridade chefiadas por mulheres mães
avós
além da criança doente ainda tem que
cuidar de várias outras
e nós vimos que o importante era um
curso sobre elas na informalidade
poderem gerar renda continuando a cuidar
das suas crianças no saúde criança nós
temos cursos na área de costura
culinária beleza mas quando interesse
habilidade da família em outra área
encaminhamos para cursos externos mas
também percebemos que não bastava isso
elas acabavam o curso e aí e aí
começamos a doar material de trabalho
alguém que acaba um curso de costura
ganha máquina de costura e aí sim pode
começar a gerar renda na sua vizinhança
na culinária mesma coisa
na batedeira assadeira e outros itens
que precise na cidadania nós orientamos
a família sobre todos os benefícios do
governo porque muitas vezes elas não
sabem que têm direito a benefícios
documentação
muita gente chega sem a documentação
completa o que nunca teve ou porque
perdeu ou extraviou numa enchente no
incêndio aconteceu alguma coisa e nós
também orientamos quanto a isso
na educação ajudando a inserir na escola
essas crianças especiais e acompanhando
a freqüência e aproveitamento questões
que a criança possa tendo que dificulta
em sua vida escolar e orientando os pais
sobre a importância da educação para os
filhos deles acompanhar a educação
temos também psicopedagoga para apoiar o
processo
na moradia muitas vezes a família está
numa casa que não tem condições de
atender a vida daquela criança doente ou
não tem um banheiro que nós temos que
construir ou não têm acessibilidade
temos que fazer uma rampa ampliar
corredores portas para que a cadeira de
roda possa circular ou casos mais
simples de resolver problemas de mofo e
infiltração problemas como falta de
ventilação
nós percebemos que o saúde criança
começou a ganhar muitos prêmios
transformar realmente a vida de famílias
porque nós atingimos várias áreas
realmente não fazemos uma maquiagem na
saúde na pobreza
vamos a fundo nas questões que as
famílias precisam
o trabalho se espalhou hoje ele está em
seis estado junto a 23 hospitais
públicos virou uma política pública em
belo horizonte influenciou
empreendedores sociais do mundo tudo
nós vimos que as famílias agora não tem
que ficar desesperadas pensando vou
comprar comida ou medicamento do meu
filho e eu gostaria de terminar falando
uma frase da marca admite nunca do vídeo
de um grupo muito comprometido de
pessoas elas podem mudar o mundo
na verdade foi assim sempre aconteceu
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]